il avait choisi de ne pas choisir
après s'être volontairement mise hors
jeu de la course aux municipales
françois xavier dugourd avait laissé
alain houpert et emmanuel bichot
s'opposer mais de guerre lasse il
revient dans le jeu en important son
soutien aux sénateurs au père tout en
prenant une liste commune d'union avec
des hommes des deux camps mais aussi du
sien
en tant que sénateur effectivement c'est
lui qui est le plus à même pour porter
cette liste et puis pour construire
cette liste d'union cette liste
indispensable unique de droite et du
centre qui doit mener le combat pour les
élections municipales je crois à sa
capacité de rassemblement de toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent s'investir dans
le combat pour dijon une liste d'union
une idée pas nouvelle jean-françois copé
l'avait déjà proposé sans réussite le
camp ou père n'acceptant pas la position
sur la liste de numéros 3 d'emmanuel
bichot ce dernier était justement en
pleine campagne hier soir présentation
de son projet devant ses soutiens pas
surpris par cette annonce il poursuit sa
candidature tout en étant d'accord pour
une liste commune pour faire l'union il
faut être deux aujourd'hui je tends la
main et je n'ai pas de réponse il ya
deux candidats les deux équipes il ya
deux projets et aucun des deux ne pourra
sortir du paysage donc la meilleure
solution c'est de faire l'union et plus
vite que nous arriverons mieux plus vite
ou seront en ordre de bataille pour
réussir l'alternance à dijon le comité
d'investiture de l'ump devrait en tout
cas tranché début octobre reste à
s'entendre sur la date de la réunion et
sur le nom mais en cas de désaccord
dijon pourrait être réservée c'est à
dire une nouvelle fois mis en attente